a new season and foreigner means a lot
of different things from new eros new
math a total revamp of the look and feel
it's the first time we do a season that
big we introduced the tournament and
ranking that's a huge activity that
periods were waiting for where they can
really play against Saucer and ensure
that were the best at the game so it's
the biggest season we've ever done so
I'm super excited to see the reception
about that
once a player understand the matchup of
all the different arrows we want to
bring new one so it shuffles the
battlefield we're bringing two new yours
to corner and your Viking G Islander but
also from the deep south of the Roman
Empire we're bringing you the gladiator
how it works on foreigners that the new
heroes are available at the beginning of
the new season for the season pass owner
and one week after that everybody can
access them so with season 3 grudge and
Rory we're introducing two brand new
maps one that is the Sentinel that is a
real castle that still has one big tower
standing The Sentinel comes with a
ballista so you can shoot other players
on the medieval better ground so it's
super cool you're the one with the
Viking village it's really capture the
feeling of that Raiders Viking village
up in the north in a cove by the water
so we're adding a new rarity rehaul
mostly for the other players that's
already completed their heroes that want
to get new visuals also for the ammo for
their weapon but also to get different
statistics at each new season we have a
breadth of new players coming into the
game so we we shorten also the
progression for them so the the first
levels the first rarities are easier to
access and then we have the high
rarities that are more for the long term
players so then everybody can find
something cool to do with with their
heroes
we're bringing the first step of a
competitive experience with tournaments
in jewel and ranking we organized slow
to 15 tournaments before the game even
shipped so for us doing tournaments is a
normal thing we pay very close attention
to what the community has been doing and
all the tournaments have been organized
so for us was just a natural step to
bring a competitive feature into the
game
that's one of the cool things that the
new season yes it's too new map to new
heroes but while also doing a lot of
improvements on this side the UI team
for example worked a lot on is the
hero's menu so now when you select an
execution when you select an image you
can see you can play with it and that's
a really cool thing that team was
working on we've take a close look at
some of our existing map and we've
looked at all the arena jewels were
behaving we've made some of those arenas
bigger we've removed some traps we've
made them less little to improve the
player experience by playing in tune to
snaps our intention we grudged glory is
to bring a breath of fresh air into the
foreigner experience because basically
what we've done since lunch that we
fixed up with improve stuff but on top
of that were adding new content were
building new content for each new season
we're adding ranking we're adding new
improvement to the customization system
we're adding new feature to the meta
game we really want to demonstrate how
long-term support and commitment to the
game and that start with season 3
[Music]